[Música]
reunimos a seis futuras novias Hola soy
Jacqueline y me voy a casar Hola soy
sebana y me voy a casar Hola soy heder y
me voy a casar Hola soy Rachel y me voy
a casar Hola soy Amy me voy a casar Hola
soy Tatiana y me voy a casar una de
ellas está divorciada si el grupo
descubre Quién es se repartirá un premio
en efectivo
si sobrevive ganará todo el premio
Quién es la impostora
[Música]
[Risas]
cuando se van a casar nos casaremos el
11:11/20
nosotros el 20 de agosto acabamos de
decidir a que nos gustaría casarnos en
septiembre de 2024 nos casaremos el día
22 del próximo Mesón es muy pronto
todavía no fijamos la fecha porque mi
prometido estudia enfermería y termina
en agosto Así que el próximo año
pensamos acordar cuando va a ser Sí al
comprometerte lo primero que quieres
hacer es planear tu boda y cómo van los
preparativos todo va muy bien de hecho
ya sabemos dónde nos casaremos serán
Minnesota eres de Minnesota No mi novio
yo soy de Wisconsin toda mi familia
nosotros queríamos casarnos donde
nacimos pero algunos miembros de la
familia no pueden viajar Así que
pensamos hacer una tradicional mexicana
mi prometido y yo hablamos sobre la
posibilidad de hacer algo íntimo
pensamos celebrarla en algún jardín No
simplemente fugarnos a medida que
envejezco me he vuelto más realista
donde ellos finanzas a cuántas personas
esperan invitar más o menos 100 igual
ella tiene mucha familia y yo también
tengo mucha familia así que Esperamos
que sean más o menos 200 sabían que se
lo iban a proponer No para nada no
quiero decir seguí enviándole pistas
pero ella lo hizo de una manera
completamente
extrañar básicamente
yo voté por semana porque no tuvo la
oportunidad de hablar así que no pude
escuchar su versión
[Música]
creo que sospecharon de mí porque no
hablé demasiado no fue por lo que dije
sino por lo que no dije bien Debemos
profundizar en los detalles Porque es lo
primero que olvidas si tu boda fue hace
mucho tiempo Cuál fue el último
proveedor que bloquearon yo a mí dije ok
todavía la estoy planeando pero fui a un
par de lugares que me interesan y tengo
el ojo puesto en uno en chino Hills es
una hermosa Hacienda que tiene establos
de caballos y cada vez que heder hace
una pregunta Amy responde primero para
que me pase por alto Así que ella
siempre trata de responder Primero me
puse en contacto con algunos fotógrafos
en instagram Pero los que me interesaron
no están disponibles Así que sigo
buscando cómo fue su compromiso la
propuesta
compromiso la mía fue inesperada
habíamos hablado de matrimonio pero no
estaba segura de cuando sería Pero
fuimos a yosomedi en septiembre un fin
de semana y me lo propuso mientras
íbamos a havedom fue perfecto hermoso Sí
mi propuesta fue en Uta Me encantan las
caminatas así que me llevó a caminar a
un hermoso lugar se llama Blake blanes y
él me propuso matrimonio después de la
caminata lo cual fue terrible porque
estaba sudando me veía terrible me veía
mal Sí
escuché que Amy cambió los pronombres y
yo no estaba muy segura pero parecía que
era su prometida es un tema delicado y
le costaba decir su pronombre bueno fue
una fiesta en Secret centa Tenemos un
apartamento pequeño y esa noche al
llegar a casa había una nota en el suelo
sigo las notas hasta el sofá en la
esquina A él le encantan los memes y
terminó con un meme de Mike wazowski
quiere ser mi esposa wasauski me volteé
el cerrodillo y lloré
pienso que ella tuvo un pequeño desliz
ella siempre se mantiene en una zona
media No sé creo que fue como dar un
tiro en la oscuridad
[Música]
Adiós chicas Adiós suelo hablar muy
rápido y me di cuenta de que pronuncié
mal su pronombre Y pensé estoy perdida
fue eso levanta en la mano si creen que
la impostora sigue en la caja y les
gustaría continuar el juego
y como decidieron continuar el juego
incluiremos una nueva regla a partir de
ahora cada vez que eliminen a alguien
que no sea la impostora se reducirá el
dinero total del premio bien díganme Qué
piensan sobre el divorcio Ah yo voy
primero
yo Tendremos una ceremonia religiosa ya
que vemos el matrimonio de una manera
muy espiritual es muy obvio pero no
quiero casarme si pienso que hay un
divorcio en el Horizonte Sí yo igual
porque cuando digo que sí me comprometo
no juzgo a nadie que se divorcie ya que
entiendo que a veces pasan cosas sí al
menos en mi caso al igual que tú conozco
gente que se ha divorciado y no quisiera
formar parte de eso ya que quiero
mostrarles el amor que siente Jesús por
ellos sí quizás se les llame la atención
Pero trabajo con las novias soy
estilista de novias Así que muchas veces
llegan novias que dicen esto no es lo
mejor para mí así que mejor pido el
divorcio para decidir su próximo paso
pero lo ideal es permanecer juntos para
siempre
ustedes tienen miedo de unirse en
matrimonio No creo que tengamos miedo Es
cierto que queremos tener bebés pero
está el dinero de la boda de la luna de
miel y para todos se necesita dinero es
una preocupación pero siento que podemos
resolver Y si estamos juntos al salir
con él llegue a conocerlo como alguien
en quien puedo confiar Juntos hacemos
una buena pareja y que trabajamos bien
resolviendo los conflictos que surgen
dijo que estaba en el mundo de las
novias y pienso que si alguien pudiera
superar esto sería alguien que estuviera
rodeada de cosas de boda
[Música]
Heather y Rachel emitía mucha emoción
con respecto a su boda así que todo se
redujo a Jack Clean
no soy una mujer muy emotiva puede ser
que me vean como alguien que no está tan
ansiosa levanten la mano y creen que la
impostora Todavía está en la caja y les
gustaría continuar el juego
es un anime el juego ha terminado si las
luces se vuelven verdes significa que
eliminaron a la impostora y todas ganan
sin embargo si las luces se vuelven
rojas significa que la impostora sigue
en la caja y perderán
[Música]
me encanta ganar Me fascina puede
revelarse la impostora
en tres
en dos uno
Hola
a todos
cuál es tu historia tenía 20 años cuando
me casé mi ex esposo tenía 10 años más
que yo lo hice Por las razones
equivocadas para que mi familia me
aceptara no aceptaban que fuera lesbiana
mi familia es muy tradicional siempre
creyeron que una vez que te casas Eso es
todo entonces para ellos fue una
vergüenza y me hicieron sentir muy mal
al final de cuentas Este es mi vida es
lo que soy sigo abierta al matrimonio
tengo una hermosa novia de quien estoy
muy enamorada y por fin mis padres la
han aceptado Así que con suerte muy
pronto me comprometeré en la escucharon
me alegro escucharte tan emocionado pero
las felicito a todas serán unas novias
hermosas estoy emocionada por usted la
próxima vez que me caso será por las
razones correctas
muy bien Lamentablemente tengo que
llevarme una parte de esto
pero no tanto
[Aplausos]
esto apenas será para pagar las flores y
todo lo demás
[Risas]